[Música]
a
escala en parís aída palau
bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio francia internacional y france 24
hoy tenemos con nosotros a uno de los
diseñadores más prometedores del momento
su firma tiene poco más de un año y
medio y ya está en los calendarios
oficiales de los desfiles parisinos se
trata del español arturo ovejero
muchísimas gracias arturo por estar con
nosotros a vosotros por invitarme bueno
tiene apenas 27 años y su apuesta no
pasa desapercibida sus diseños han
sucumbido ya personalidades como carla
bruni o pamela anderson algún día se
imaginaba que tan pronto tendría calado
entre las personalidades a ver la verdad
es que suerte con suerte está pasando
todo muy orgánicamente y luego que nadie
se piense que es carla bruni en whatsapp
escribiendo de arturo en este vestido
hay un proceso detrás hay estilistas
editores
estoy muy agradecido me apoyen mucho y
me piden roque para este tipo de
personalidades bueno antes de hablar de
su universo y de sus creaciones vamos a
presentarle un poquito nació en un
pueblo del norte de españa en asturias
tapia de casariego un pueblo costero en
el seno de una familia surfera y fue el
diseñador británico alexander mcqueen el
que fue un poco determinante para decir
bueno yo quiero hacer esto no quiero
quiero hacer moda estudia primero en
galicia y luego en la prestigiosa
escuela saint martins de londres y
enseguida cuando termina le llaman de
lanza en parís que es una de las casas
de moda más antiguas del mundo y allí ya
se traslada de londres a parís entra en
la industria casi por una de las puertas
más grandes que le aporta su paso por
por lado
lambán me aporta una experiencia
internacional que nunca había tenido la
suerte de trabajar un hombre es tan
grande como tú decías la marca de alta
costura más antigua de francia
fue muy privilegiado de haber visto
muchísimas piezas de los archivos que
son increíbles también me llevo
compañeros increíbles de la experiencia
y también aprendí a cómo manejar mi
tiempo que qué es lo que quiero
conseguir a largo plazo lo que no quiero
conseguir también y
pero durante esa experiencia se da
cuenta enseguida que lo que quiere es
lanzar su propia marca que no quiere no
quiere esperar arturo ovejero que
encuentra además la inspiración en sus
raíces no en ese pueblo costero también
en el flamenco en el mundo de los toros
y en la danza que es un aspecto muy
importante en sus diseños una apuesta
muy poética cuál es el mensaje que
quiere transmitir qué quiere decir
arturo ovejero más que un mensaje yo
creo que lo que intento hacer con mis
mis colecciones es que la moda más que
más que nunca necesita tener sustancia
detrás debía tener un poco de jugó
porque si no al final solamente creamos
productos y es el camino me interesa yo
creo que quiero crear piezas que tengan
alma y trabajo detrás que la gente pueda
apreciar toda la vida empiezas en mucha
calidad
y sí que les ayude que les empodere y
que les haga sentir como como tú decides
como mis bailarines favoritos por
ejemplo que se pongan mis prendas
iniciales del porte y que salgan a la
calle como como si fuesen al escenario a
comérselo siente que la moda se ha
vuelto un poco superficial que siente
esta necesidad de sí tristemente sí
evidentemente hay muchos jóvenes
soñadores que estamos luchando para que
esto no pase pero yo creo que debido a
redes sociales estamos muy acostumbrados
tú como periodista lo sabrás incluso a
consumir información
super rápido sin pensar estamos
contaminados constantemente
constantemente y me lo comete es tomarme
el tiempo poco a poco y eso si le hablo
de la película la piel que habito de
pedro almodóvar que tan importante ha
sido en su trayectoria pues la verdad es
que muy importante porque al principio
era solamente una de mis películas
favoritas y luego durante el primer año
del máster en londres el primer proyecto
era sobre el research investigación y yo
utilicé la piel que habito' como mi como
mi base mis pilares
escribió al equipo de almodóvar él me
contestó
y me envió un guión firmado me envió
información documentos y es una película
con la que estaba obsesionado
bueno la sastrería torera es
importantísima en sus diseños qué
elementos ha introducido de esos trajes
de de toreros en sus piezas y cuales
bueno se han quedado
a mí lo que más me interesa de la
sastrería torera más que nada la silueta
la dualidad entre lo masculino lo
femenino y me quería centrar como te
decía en la esencia de la silueta
los pantalones altos las chaquetas
cortas los puños los chalecos las
camisas pero todo como siempre
intentando huir de
florituras centrándome en la silueta y
en la en la pureza de las líneas
bueno historias son súper masculinos o
se supone que tienen que ser masculinos
brutos no rudos
sin embargo usted la llama de la
atención que esa ropa es muy femenina
y ese es el punto tal vez el que le
interese de bueno de confusión de
géneros
sin más que confusión de géneros es que
me interesa la androginia me interesa la
ambigüedad me interesa porque es como yo
me siento y como
mucha gente de nuestra generación
también se siente y de generaciones
pasadas esto no es nada nuevo muchas
veces creemos que estamos haciendo algo
nuevo pero esto lleva pasando desde
siempre no sé cuando decidimos que de
repente los hombres tenemos que ser tan
aburridos vistiendo siempre todos igual
como decías me interesaba del mundo los
toreros que originariamente
eran hombres como tú bien super rudos
jugando en el campo y en todas las
mujeres los vestían con el resto de sus
telas de ahí que tengan todo sus
bordados los colores los terciopelos y a
mí me encanta su actualidad que tú ves a
un hombre súper varonil o masculino pero
de repente con un traje súper femenino
que a la vez si lo pones en una mujer se
ve súper masculino o lo que consideramos
que es en la sociedad masculino o
femenino hay ropa sin género
si la ropa al final del día la ropa es
un rectángulo de tela en la que tú pones
tu patrón lo cortas y de ahí le das la
forma o la silueta que quieres o sea que
no tiene género para nada se ha
decantado más por la semana de la moda
masculina que por la
la femenina
explícanos por qué yo creo que a ver yo
originariamente empecé haciendo ropa de
mujer luego en el másters y que me
empujaron y me decían tu visión en el
mundo del hombre es mucho más innovadora
mucho más fresca y de ahí empecé
entonces siempre para conseguir a
continuar haciendo mujer pero quiero
empujar más la visión el nombre y cuál
es la pieza maestra de arturo viajero a
ver maestra no soy yo maestra de su
autorización de persona de en cuanto a
silueta se refiere yo creo que de la
primera colección palmira hay una pieza
que se llama covadonga que es
literalmente una taleguilla torera pero
exagerada y de las últimas un top que se
llama pedrero que está hecho con los
cristales de mi pueblo que encuentras en
la playa en el mar en
y entonces recolecte con los niños de mi
pueblo y creamos un top juntos en su
apuesta hay un eje central que es el de
huir de la sobreproducción
y también reutiliza telas de las que se
descartan de grandes casas como si venia
y fendi es viable esta forma de producir
es viable es mucho más complicado porque
no puedes tener lo que quiere es el
momento que quieres cuando lo quieres
pero yo creo que estamos muy muy mal
acostumbrados a tener eso lo que
queremos cuando lo queremos y yo creo
que también tenemos que
aceptar el cómo estamos dejando el mundo
como lo estamos tratando y tenemos que
darnos cuenta de que producir por
producir no nos lleva a ningún ningún
lado todo lo contrario y yo no veo mi
marca arturo vejer o como una marca
multimillonaria no me interesa ser el
hombre más rico más poderoso del mundo
mí no me interesa yo quiero crecer
orgánicamente poco a poco montar un
equipo en el que crea
y eso sobrevivir en la colección puro
teatro es el leit motiv le lleva incluso
a hacer sus diseños con cortinas de
teatro cuéntenos cómo fue ese proceso
que son cortinas como de terciopelo no
son terciopelo rojo fue una locura
primero encontrar todas las cortinas y
luego también lo hicimos durante el
confinamiento o sea que estaba yo como
te comentaba en mi casa en mi pequeño
estudio
y me parecía que también la idea de
utilizar de reutilizar o rescatar las
cortinas me pareció muy romántica porque
estas cortinas son testigos de los
abucheos de los aplausos de sacrificio
de muchos artistas y el ser capaz de
llevar prendas con tanta historia detrás
con tanta
narrativa detrás me parecía súper bonito
bueno y está preparando su próxima
colección que se va a presentar en enero
explíquenos un poquito si puede
adelantarnos algo a ver no puedo plantar
mucho porque estoy en pleno proceso
creativo o sea que puede que ahora estás
en la colección pero igual en dos
semanas cambio completamente pero
te puedo contar está muy relacionado con
la música con la música clásica pero
luego con mi twist con mi
visión digamos y está a punto de sacar
porque se está diversificando su primer
perfume si es un proyecto que llevamos
un año trabajando en él es una
colaboración que hicimos con una casa de
perfumes pigmentario en la república
checa
son dos artistas los que llevan a la
casa y tenemos los sacamos oficialmente
el día 29 de septiembre
tenemos un evento aquí en parís en el de
bastón y luego el día 7 en la república
checa en praga y estamos muy contentos
bueno y si le digo balenciaga mcqueen o
la abuela palmira quien la influido más
a ver cada uno yo creo que su padrino en
su parte digamos en mi abuela es mi
abuela mi abuela es no nada más que
decir es tu abuela es tu familia es el
pilar de mi casa ahora por ejemplo que
está ella sola en mi casa es como que la
veneramos todos la faraona casi
luego balenciaga lo admiro muchísimo
porque me parece una persona super
discreta muy íntima un genio también en
cuanto a construcción
y que tenía mucho carácter además luego
de mcqueen me encanta la capacidad de
fantasía creada y también de aportar
mensajes políticos con sus colecciones
que es algo que me interesa mucho y
antes de terminar de su casa
de la abuela palmira
recupera no en cosas flores por ejemplo
bordados de flores
explíquenos si yo soy mucho de barrer
para casa como decía soy de tapia de
casariego de asturias que es soy muy
orgulloso de este un orgulloso y
agradecido estar este pueblo
por ejemplo una condición llamada
nordeste que estaba inspirada en son los
bailarines de la ópera de garnier de
parís pero su nuevo escenario es mi
pueblo pues hicimos bordados con las
hortencias de mi abuela también hicimos
piezas en azabache con el típico
azabache asturiano
prendas inspiradas en los trajes
surferos como mi familia
prendas inspiradas en los trajes de
gaiteros gaiteros por ejemplo o sea que
con cada colección poco a poco intento
eso barrer para casa porque y no
solamente por barrer para casa sino
porque es quien soy es mi esencia y es
lo que vi cuando crecí y es lo que me
hace ser quien soy bueno pues muchísimas
gracias
arturo ovejero por esta entrevista y le
deseamos mucho éxito gracias a ustedes
y muchísimas gracias a todos ustedes por
habernos acompañado ya saben que nos
pueden seguir en internet en rf y
mundo.com france24 puntocom hasta pronto
amigos
[Música]